Thank you. Let's get right to
it. Uh, the obsidian collection,
that term obsidian comes
from a volcanic rock.
It's a dark glass that's
formed when lava and dirt,
certain explosions,
all of that come about.
So there are lots of obsidian around
Hawaii and other places where there are
volcanoes. I love the name because I
think that's what black culture is.
Beautiful Black, shiny, formed
from high pressure, heat,
et cetera. And that's what we're
doing. The obsidian collection,
we're collecting the black archives,
but more than just that we're digitizing
them and making them available for
younger generations.
And as I started the project just
a little bit over three years ago,
we were asked why,
why are you doing that?
There's already archive groups
that are collecting history.
The universities are collecting it.
And uh, we got that big beautiful new,
uh,
Black Smithsonian in DC.
So why do you need to form
the obsidian collection?
And I think I can best communicate
that and telling you about my love of
football. Now I know it's going to,
it's going to work its way back around.
But I love football.
I Love Chicago bears football.
And I can tell you from when I was
five to seven years old, I was,
my dad's friends would come over.
We had a giant floor model TV and they
would let me get the beer and they will
let me empty the ash trays.
Now this is the late sixties
early seventies so beer
cans were made of like what
I would think was solid titanium steel.
And the ashtrays were these
huge ceramic platters.
So my responsibility was important.
I remember the screens be in green,
they're being white lines on the screen.
People would crash into each other.
And then my father and his friends
would either cheer or gea and it was
football. And I love
football. Now fast forward,
I started seeing football throughout
my life and I know how football works,
the x's and the o's lineup.
Then they crash into each other and then
somebody throws in the yellow towel and
then people stand around
like this and then they wait,
and then the guys and the stripes
come out and do some things.
And then they either say this way or
they say that way and then you cheer or
[inaudible]. Now I've been
watching football my whole life.
I would argue with you that I love
football just like any other American.
And I love the Chicago bears.
I'm a native Chicago.
But imagine if I was the
curator of the Chicago bears,
I would put together an exhibit and it
would be all of the collisions, right?
Because that's what they kind of do.
They run into each other a lot.
They line up and then they run
into each other and then they,
then somebody throws the towel.
I've seen it.
So what I would do is I would have an
exhibit of all the collisions and then I
would have another exhibit of the towels
because they went from like a mustard
and then they started being more yellow.
I do remember that.
And then I know when some of the bigger
games they pour containers of water on
each other at the end of big wins.
I do know that to not,
it doesn't make a lot of sense,
but that's happens in football.
And I love football.
So one of my exhibits is going to be all
the coolers of water dunking on people
because that's football
to me and I love football.
Now somebody who actually likes football
would go to my exhibit and inside of 15
seconds they would go,
what is this?
And this isn't football.
They are layers to football.
And there's a whole ecosystem and
culture around football and this isn't
football.
And that's what happens with a lot of
African Americans that walk into an
exhibit and go,
what is this?
It's people who just
focus on the collisions.
So you just here picking protests,
slave struggle, and it's like, um,
look,
there are layers to this thing.
This isn't the sum total
of the black experience.
And just like me with football,
and this is true because that is my
understanding of football. I would say,
well, explain football to me. And then
people who know football, like, look,
you just don't know for a ball and you
can't be in charge of it. It's not.
It's okay that you think you love it or
whatever your association is with it.
That's not the sum total of football.
And I remember my senior year of college,
the bears went to the Superbowl
and I watched it with everybody.
And again,
they lined up.
I don't know what the problem is cause
that's what happened. They lined up,
there was a snap, somebody man, this
way, somebody, they ran into each other,
somebody throwing the towel. This is
what, this is what I see. And I love it.
But I loved everything around it.
I'm football adjacent, I'm not,
I don't, I should not be in charge
of telling the story of football.
So it was then when one of
my friends said after they,
after we won, I know we won. I do
that, that we won that Superbowl.
The um, one of my friends said, who
do you think is going to be the MVP?
I didn't know what an MVP was,
but everybody burst into conversation and
they started discussing these plays in
these little nuances and
all of this other stuff.
And that's when I realized I don't
know what they're talking about.
And that's how black culture is.
You can be adjacent and you can love it,
but there's a lot of layers to it
and it's important that there be an
independent free standing organization
run by black people to cure rate that
story because we can walk
into an exhibit and go,
I get it. It's a protest
struggle, SSA slave.
It's a lynching. It's like, it's
like that's all that's there.
So it's important for us to
take the narrative back and
that's what the obsidian
collection is doing.
So we started with the Chicago defender.
Now many people know,
and I don't want to preach to the choir,
but the Chicago defenders started in
1904 and it's essential to black history
because as we were freed his slaves,
everybody needed to know.
People wanted to start migrating away
and the Chicago defender was different
from other newspapers and they took the
initiative to actually start getting
these newspapers down south.
So they partnered with the Pullman porters
and the Pullman porters were in a way
to make extra money. They were
distributed in selling the papers.
When in down south it was kind of frowned
upon for black people to actually even
read,
let alone get the scoop on where to go.
So the Chicago defender actually helped
show black Americans what was going on
in the rest of the states, where they
should go, where safe passage was,
what to dress like when you come up north,
what to wear.
All of those good things came
through the Chicago defender and um,
the Chicago defender had sold the family,
the original family from 1904.
So the paper in about 2007,
the theory was that all of the images
were taken by the family and then some
were given to the library,
some to Getty, et cetera.
And there weren't that many images laugh.
So when we came there,
we thought they were going to be 10,000
images and we found actually 250,000
images in this one room.
And what happened to me was you can't see
250,000 images of yourself and ever be
the same. Right? So it was like
being bit by a radioactive spider.
We said we got to get
this information out and,
and I've learned through my own child
that young people get everything through
the smartphone.
So when I was telling my son about some
of the stories and some of the things we
found, he would go right to his smart
phone and say, well that's not in here.
And you know, are you
spelling it right? You know,
and I remember in my own naivety,
I thought when the Internet was invented
that everything was automatically on
the Internet. Like, well now it's on the
Internet now through some kind of magic,
what I came to learn was we weren't
digitizing the black newspapers.
The black photo journalists
weren't getting,
there just weren't specific platforms
to get the information out there so that
younger and future generations
can immediately access it.
So that's one of the things
we started with the Chicago,
the Chicago defender was our first
effort and now we have a lot of black
newspapers in the queue to share their
images so we can get them out so that
everybody can see him
until fabulous new stories.
So what John mentioned, we, we
have a wonderful partnership.
Our first immediate platform is through,
uh,
Google Arts and culture who we met
through the black Googler network.
And we started by just
putting up some images.
Now these are just three of a quarter
of a million. And so, you know,
I narrowed it down. You're
welcome. And uh, but the,
the first image I like a lot because
it's just one of the secretaries when the
Chicago defender move their offices
into the south loop of Chicago,
that's an important play.
That story is on the Google Arts and
culture obsidian page and it's a series of
images,
but just being able to accomplish a
feet like that back in those days.
And then there were printers in the
basement and all of those other feeds.
Those are, those are the kind of place
that we would discuss amongst ourselves.
That's the kind of information that would,
would,
that's the narrative of
how we see ourselves. Um,
aside from just the newspapers
and the photographers,
we've got small community archives
joining us. And so the other picture,
the opposite one is a Fred
Hutchinson with a plane.
Wonderful story of this guy who
wanted to fly planes. But as a,
a black man in the early 1920s,
there was a nonstarter,
but his family was a family of means.
So his father bought him an airplane
and so he learned how to fly by starting
the plane,
getting in it and flying it.
And Landon, you know, that
he, that happened and uh,
and that, that was hidden. There was
a small plane, a single engine plane,
but he wanted to learn how to
fly the commercial airplane.
So he moved to Canada and he joined
the Royal Canadian Air Force where he
learned, then he eventually moved to
Haiti and opened up a black flight school.
But by then we were entering World War
II and America had decided we're going to
need some black pilots.
So he actually became a flight
instructor for the Tuskegee airman.
So that story is from
shorefront legacy archives.
They've been collecting the history of
the black people who lived on the gold
coast in the 19 hundreds that's
a story that doesn't get told,
but it was a lot of them.
And that was, you know what,
120 years ago,
but we were there too.
So shorefront has a great archive
and now the obsidian platform,
they've joined us and we'll be able
to get those stories to the world.
The one in the middle,
it's just one of my favorite photos
because it's just black boy joy.
I raised a black sign in in Chicago and,
and the kids have fun,
but that's not the narrative
that's in the mainstream.
But my life was fun. My son's
life was fun. If he says it's not,
he's lying was amazing.
I was an awesome parent.
But those,
we've got a ton of images like that.
This is one of my favorite and this just
helps me communicate that we're not,
I'm not doing this alone
because I'm not an archivist.
They will let you know that, that uh,
that's a postgraduate degree industry.
I am not an archivist. I
am not a historian. They
will let you know that too.
Uh, and that's a phd process.
So what I am as a storyteller,
but I've aligned our s with experts
and we're creating new experts.
This picture,
the man with the hat is Joe Lewis and
he's a famous boxer and I knew he was a
boxer because when I was a kid we drank
Joe Lewis milk and on the cover he was
posing like this and he had on boxing
gloves. So I knew he was boxing.
I didn't know he was one of the most
famous boxes ever. Blah, blah blah.
But that's Joe Lewis,
the guy in the metal judge Duke Slater.
Duke is the first African American
linemen to play in the NFL.
And that story doesn't
get that much coverage.
I will spare you in long and short.
The in NFL in 1926 he was,
he's got one of the best records. It was
just broken recently by a Chicago bear,
but the NFL let five black people play
in 1926 then they hokey pokey and it back
and said no, no black
players. So he, it went down,
it was five then it went down to zero.
So he was the first head coach and formed
the Chicago Negro All star football
team and after he retired football.
And this,
you're just as long story about that,
but we'll get those narratives out
there because it's a good story.
In 1928 he actually got his law degree.
So after he retired from football,
he became an assistant assistant district
attorney and then he's the second
elected judge in Chicago.
That is an important
part of our narrative.
We got to get those stories out
there so that this is second nature.
But the picture in the defender archives,
they were on the back.
It was written judge
Duke's later and Joe Lewis.
So I put that on Google Arts and
culture. That's it. Those two.
So one of my friends call
me who's 60 and he said,
why don't you credit the other guy?
Now you as people of a certain age know
who that is, right? You know that it is.
I didn't know who that was and it wasn't
written on the back because you know my
love of sports, but I won't bury the lead
too much longer. That's Jackie Robinson.
Now I only know one image of Jackie
Robinson is the one that's on the trading
card when he was 24 and so my friend said,
I'm gonna need you to write Jackie
Robinson's name up there. And I said,
but it doesn't say Jackie
Robinson on the back.
And that's not how
you're supposed to do it.
You're supposed to record the history
that it's accurate. And he said, you know,
and
anybody with a pulse of a certain age
wouldn't have thought to need to write
Jackie Robinson's name.
So I would tell younger people,
it's like if you had 100
pictures of Lebron James,
you wouldn't feel the need to make
sure you wrote his name on every page.
But fast forward 50 years later,
some child that has not been
born yet is going to go, what?
No name on there.
So we threw that out.
So I asked five other people who were
over 60 do you know who this isn't even
looking at me like is this a cause? You
know who that is? Right. And I was like,
well I'm just trying to see if you know,
you know before we actually put
Jackie Robinson's name on there.
But the other beauty about this
photograph is these were three captains of
sports, boxing, football and baseball.
And they were actually
playing golf because Joe Lewis
made serious inroads into
pro am and the PGA.
And so this for black people
who knows sports better than I,
but you know, I know football, the, these,
these kinds of stories and these pictures,
they knew they were taking an iconic
photo and we've got to make sure that not
only do we get the photo,
but we've got to get the elders involved
to make sure we get the good Intel on
there. Cause I know everything
else really well except sports.
But we also have added more than
just photo journalism in history.
We've got a fashion and
beauty photographer,
Ernest Collins loaned us 120 images that
we put up for black history month this
year.
So on our Google arts and culture page,
we've added a lot of fashion and beauty
specifically because that's part of our
history.
The key part of that is we also
want to alter the metadata.
So when you go and Google
black man in Chicago,
primarily what's being populated,
our news outlets and crime.
So you don't, you only get
images from 1940 if you're lucky,
but you mainly get crime.
So it's important that as the obsidian
uploads all of this metadata onto the
Internet, when you type in black
man, black woman, all of this,
we're going to be populating it with,
uh,
hundreds of thousands of images that
are not the collisions because that's
already been done.
So we're picking the,
the real intricacies of the
culture of the layers to this game.
So let's get back to reclaiming
the Chicago narrative.
And let's talk about
Bronzeville. I'm going to go
over what a lot of people know,
maybe others don't. But this is one of
my favorite photos. So we don't own this.
When this was actually owned by the
library of Congress and it's completely
royalty free.
It was shot in 1940 1941 and most of us,
this is the Goto photograph
for Bronzeville, but this was,
this was just a photographer come to here.
Another narrative about
how brands Bronzeville was,
but he just stopped five ordinary boys
who were on their way to Sunday school
and said,
take a picture in front of this car,
because that's what Bronzeville looked
like. If we're writing the story,
this is just another day in the life,
everybody dress like that.
All of the images from my childhood,
that's what they looked like.
So Bronzeville was called the black belt,
but there was also a restricted covenant.
So as we were moving in droves from
about 1916 forward 1916 and 1948 it was a
law on the books that black people
could only live in a specific area.
And that was to call
the restricted covenant.
So we all piled into Bronzeville.
It's not the Bronzeville proper today,
it's about seven of those neighborhoods
and it's a big part of the south side.
So with the black belt,
somehow we had three hospitals,
six newspapers,
1000 small black owned businesses,
2000 people worked in the numbers game
and we were three times densely more
densely populated than
the rest of Chicago.
So if you pick the a certain
series of blocks in north side,
there'd be 20,000 people that same
square footage in Bronzeville,
60,000 so we were piled in,
but it wasn't what the narrative,
kind of what the narrative I've
been reading kind of leads us to.
It was vibrant.
So we had the Jones department store,
we had the palm tavern, we went
to the theaters, we had clubs.
Bronzeville was really extremely exciting,
populated and vibrant.
I'm stunned at this current narrative
that kind of implies, again,
just collisions of,
I dunno,
they came here and Gosh, we got to help
them. And it's like, wait, you're, you're,
you're leaving something out.
So we've got to get that online so
you guys can go to it as quickly as,
what I love about the youth culture
is somebody puts out a fact,
you guys clap back so fast with all kinds
of facts and links and hyperlinks is
like boom, boom, boom, boom.
And so we've got to get this information
digitize so that you can clap back
against these negative stories.
I don't know if it's that they are
black adjacent or if it's malicious,
I don't know. But the truth
will set us all free and easy,
quick access to the truth will
get us there. So I'll leave it to,
I'll leave the clap back to you
guys cause I can't text that fast,
but we'll get the information out there
so that you can have access to it.
But I was trying to figure out how did
we do all of that with out all of this
help that has become the new narrative.
Like oh my goodness,
if we don't help them by, you know,
eliminating their entire culture,
then they won't be helped.
So what we also did was formed
what we call the elder circle.
And we started talking to
people from Bronzeville.
We've started interviewing and
filming them and talking to them,
getting the nuances of what's happening
in Chicago and what happened back in
those days.
Now the guy in the corner is
not a of that same generation.
His Nathan Thompson who wrote
a book called the Policy Kings,
and actually we'll be doing a documentary,
we'll be doing film.
There's a lot that will be going on that
will be explaining why Bronzeville was
vibrant. And it was mainly
because of the number runners.
Now I'll say this,
the uh,
and now because I don't want to give
that story away cause that's coming.
But essentially those were the guys
who played, who ran the numbers,
which is like the lottery. I think it's
important when I'm telling the story,
I'm starting a narrative of 1746.
The New York general assembly had a
lottery and they built king's college,
which went on to become
Columbia University.
So when somebody else is telling the
story a lottery is acceptable. But,
and then when we did lottery it became,
you know,
thuggery and illegal and
illicit and all of those things.
That's why it's important to
drive your own narratives.
But the policy king's lived
in the community and they
actually invested in the
community and if you want to
just open up a small business,
you would get a small business
loan from a policy king.
So that's how we were able to
be vibrant and self sufficient.
So I want to make sure that we
get that information to you guys.
So that's kind of the overview of what
the obsidian collection is and why we're
doing it and what it is.
So to take that forward,
I am going to invite my colleague,
my young colleague,
who has been amazing and bold in that
she's one of the cofounders of the tribe
and they are a
digital platform that speaks to
millennials. I'll say this, when I saw it,
I was like, I don't know who some of
these people are. My son was like, oh,
I know all these people are.
And he immediately joined the tribe.
I've joined it too, but I'm going
to bring Morgan up to the stage.
Let's give Morgan.
Thank you.
So first I want to ask you
to tell everyone what is oh,
to tell everyone what is the tribe?
Sure.
So the tribe is a publication
and production company
with a mission to reshape
the narrative of black Chicago.
And we were born out of resistant to
the dominant narrative of Chicago,
which is that the dominant
narrative of black Chicago, right?
Which is that we are a violent
throwaway community and especially black
millennials in youth that we are not
invested in or that we don't care about
black lives, which,
um, is, is a gross lie.
So, um, I did a crazy thing and I said,
I can't take it anymore.
I can't continue to watch the news
and see black bodies on the ground.
I can't continue to read the newspapers
and see sensationalist headlines about
what the body count was
this weekend. And, um,
I called one of my best friends who I
went to Northwestern width and I said,
what can we do? Um, she's a journalist
and I talked to her and I said,
why don't you quit your
job at your newspaper,
move back to Chicago and write
about what you care about.
And that's what we did. Is that
Tiffany? That's Tiffany. Yeah.
Cause what I love about you guys'
logo is it's, it's, it's forward,
it's progressive,
it's young and it's,
I guess the tribe.
Why did you call it the trial?
We needed it to feel communal and we want
it black Chicago to feel like this is
ours. That we are finally taking back
our narrative. I want you to talk about,
that's Tiffany, that's you in the middle.
And tell me who the other gentleman is.
Um, that's David. He's our
web developer and designer.
So he's the one that
came up with that logo.
And it's funny because I actually pushed
back with him on it and then he said,
I thought you wanted to do news
different. And I was like, you know what?
You're right. We're not going
to look like your typical, uh,
mainstream media platform.
This is going to look like a movement.
We're going to brand it. It's
going to be a lifestyle. Yeah.
Well as grade one of the things
I, when I met Morgan, um,
I was so moved by the entrepreneurship.
It reminds me of all of the
entrepreneurship that I've
learned in the archives
and then the history.
But one of the things I wanted to
make sure everybody understood.
One of the platforms you
guys did was shy vote.
Can you tell us about that?
We're a small collective. Really.
There really is three of us.
And so many people think that
we're this huge conglomerate.
But really we hire
freelancers and we hire, um,
black voices to help tell these stories
about black Chicago. But at our core,
we thought there's no way that we're
going to be able to take on the elections
with all the 5 million candidates
that there are. So what can we do?
So I said, why don't we reach out to
other independent platforms and say,
can we come together and amplify each
other's stories so that we're not
duplicating the same efforts and then
create an election guide together?
And that's what we did. So we reached
out to the better government association,
Chicago reporter, the daily
line, Black Club, shy south side,
weekly,
a bunch of organizations to put together
this nonpartisan election guide.
So it's shy.vote.
That's great.
What do you think that the Obsidian,
the platform that we're building,
which should launch later this year,
how do you think that those tools
can help what you guys are doing?
Well, we had the same mission. It's all
about reshaping the black narrative. Um,
black youth are not being told
the truth about who we are.
It's not taught in schools.
Um,
there's no way for us to find some of
this information really until we get to
college.
When we get to college,
that may be the first time that we start
reading texts by black authors. So,
um, when I think about the news and I
think about a hundred years from now,
what are people going to go to,
to reference what Black
Chicago is right now?
Can you really look at the
archives of the Tribune or,
or any anywhere and say this is a
full picture of what black Chicago is,
when the majority of that is going
to be headlines about who was slain.
So we see the tribe as someone and the
obsidian collection as someone who can
step in and say,
here is a more holistic,
multifaceted view of
who we are as a people.
That's great.
I think what I was hoping to make sure
we accomplish is that people can get
involved and follow the
tribe and all of that.
But tell me one of the fun stories or one
of the important stories that you guys
covered as the tribe that matter to
you, that, that does the stick out.
Cause I know they all matter.
Sure. It's, we have a series on
our site called out west. Um,
Tiffany who's the cofounder of the
tribe and the editor and chief. Um,
she's from north Lawndale.
It's okay. West side.
Um,
but you know,
everybody talks about the stories of the
south side because there's so many kind
of vibrant middle class communities,
but people just leave the west side either
the dialogue completely when it comes
to west Chicago.
Um,
and so we wanted to focus on
a series that talks about, um,
Tiffany's routes to the west side and
also the great migration and that journey,
um, to the west side and why, um,
the west side is kind of like
the city's forgotten stepchild.
So we actually journey to
Mississippi together. Uh,
we found out Tiffany and I that our
families are both from Bolivar County.
And so we went there to kind
of discover the past. And, um,
it's a very fascinating story.
If you look at this series about us as
young people discovering who we are by
rechecks true, retracing the, the
roots of our grandmothers. So,
so you use a lot of things
more than just text.
You use videos and you
create documentaries.
Well, absolutely. So my background
is that I'm a filmmaker.
And so while Tiffany is your
more traditional journalists,
I'm coming in like,
no,
we're not doing this the regular news way.
I don't care about the 24 hour news
cycle and what's trending on Twitter.
Let's do more long form stories that
going to matter later on. You know,
so I use my documentary film
background to tell, um, um,
like to make,
to create documentary series
the multimedia stories
because I'm in this day and
age,
not everyone's going to read the text,
but you need something
that's going to go on.
Social media grabbed their attention.
So we like to use audio, video,
all different types of
mediums to tell stories.
Wow.
Okay.
Well I think we've covered everything
that we wanted to talk about today and we
can open it up to questions
if anybody has any.
As I sit here and listen
to you guys both present,
I'm feel with goosebumps in terms of the
power of both of your platforms to tell
new stories for our African
American experience.
So I want to thank you guys
for this presentation and
just really appreciate it.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
How sponsors responded to your site.
I'm actually very well,
we, I sell the tribe.
I keep it real with people.
When I'm selling the tribe.
Nobody's going to tell stories about black
Chicago like weekend until they start
hiring black people.
So that hasn't happened.
So we're going to be your best voice
for telling stories about black people.
Yeah.
So they really come to us because they
want to reach our audience like you want
to get, um, I mean black millennials
are coming into like buying power.
Everybody's interested in that.
So yeah,
people are really approach
us along those lines.
How can we best support you,
both of you and your organizations?
You go first.
Money.
Money is always an answer.
I wish there was another answer I can
give you. Um, but we had the creativity,
we have the,
the education.
We have a conglomerate of creatives who
are ready and can't get hired at legacy
papers. So yeah, if we have money we can,
we can tell more stories and that
is the best way to help us out.
If we can talk afterwards
if you're interested.
Oh my gosh, I love her. Because I,
I want to say Ditto to that,
but,
um, gosh, I just love these young
people because that's it. I, I would've,
I think my generation would have
said the exact same thing and,
and so many more words.
I would have stretched that out to
about seven or eight sentences. But, um,
you know, with my formal education
and all that. But I think that's,
that's what we're going to be
reaching out for that as well.
Hi, thanks so much for being here. Um,
what kind of conversations are happening
with teachers and with like the CPS
system to kind of help,
um,
with these gaps in the narrative that
you're talking about because it's
obviously such a crucial piece of this.
Well,
I appreciate you asking that because
both of my parents were teachers and I,
so I, I know way more about
teaching than football.
But one of the things that we're doing
at the obsidian is we are going to be
creating educational content as well.
But the interesting thing about education
right now is it has gotten very narrow,
right? But people are teaching
to a very standardized, uh,
systems. And, and it,
it doesn't leave a lot of room
for extra curricular that way,
but the charter school system is
coming up and, and, and even they,
I've already been talking to them.
It's, it's just a very narrow space.
But we're working with
virtual reality and,
and some of all these other things so
that when that relaxes a little bit
because I'm excited that
that places like Google and,
and these big tech firms are moving
away from these traditional narrow
requirements and that's allowing
for a lot more creativity.
We feel like with these platforms we can
get the knowledge and information out
even if it doesn't come through
organized curriculum systems.
So we're just going to keep creating
and then you young people just keep
inventing.
Just when I figured out this tool
now everything is on the virtual.
So we're going to get it there and then
we'll get the information out there.
Cause you guys are taking in information
so many different ways. Yeah.
Let me add onto that because I love
talking to teachers about education.
I think we need to totally reframe
the way that we teach about history.
Um,
and I always tell this story.
I remember being in about seventh or
eighth grade and my social studies teacher
wrote on the board and huge
letters manifest destiny.
And we're literally talking about the u
s going through and stealing everybody's
land and just massacring people.
And we'd call that section
in history manifest destiny.
So I need for teachers
to start teaching from
the point of view of the oppressed.
And if the title of the texts in
history sounds like a comic book,
then it's probably wrong.
And we need to like reassess
what we're teaching our kids.
I, uh, first of all, I want to
say that, um, from my perspective,
you nailed it on football.
What's the problem? What I see,
right? Um, but curiously, exactly.
Um, uh, model any Hendrick,
I'm both a columnist for the sun times
and president of the National Association
of black journalists. And I
just want to say that, you know,
I'm more of a comment than a small
question and that is that I'm blown away.
I'm blown away. Um, you know, I've,
I've heard about your project, I've,
I've read bits and pieces,
but today,
just sitting there in the,
in the few minutes that you
went over some of the photos,
you told me stories I didn't even
know. And, and you know, and,
and yeah, I think I know everything,
you know, but, but I'm saying, you know,
as black journalists and as veterans,
we think we pretty much know the history,
but there were pieces that history you
told me, just little small photos. Um,
the one about the guy who,
Fred, is it Fred? Oh my God,
I've never heard of him. I was like,
oh my, I made a note, go look him up.
And you know,
son turn those archives
over to shorefront legacy.
His grandson is still
lives in Evanston and that,
that's amazing. And then, um, just to say,
you know, Morgan, of course, Hey Morgan,
I am so, so proud of Morgan and,
and she and Tiffany and her team,
um, you know, they just started their
stars, their Navj stars here in Chicago.
Um, the one thing I wanted to ask you
is, so as I sat here listening to it,
I was struck by how do I,
I mean,
besides telling the story
of the obsidian collective,
how do we share those photos?
I mean,
in terms of when you think about
copyright and like if, if the Sun Times,
if I wanted to do a story on
with the gallery of these photos,
how were they being allowed?
I'm glad you asked that too.
So we, we've got lawyers
and uh, and and so I've learned a
lot about copyright law but the,
a big part of the obsidian
collection platform,
we're building a very expensive
website. Uh, yeah. Uh,
is that is going to be a quick access to
licensing and permissions so that it's
going to rival kind of the other stock
photo images out there as well as a
platform for viewing and
pleasure and enjoyment.
But there will be quick access and that
is a revenue share model so that the
owners retain ownership
and then can monetize.
What it does is it allows revenue to
go into these small archive groups that
need those dollars.
And then it makes it a available
for you to tell the stories because,
uh,
the Schaumburg Library,
which gathered all of
the Harlem Information,
the reason Harlem is written
more about then Bronzeville was,
is because you had access
to the information.
The Schaumburg is actually gathered up
all the images and then you could go in
there and licensing and tell
all these stories. Right.
That hasn't been nearly as
easy. And Bronzeville, I,
uh, I do the licensing and permissions
for the Chicago defender right now and we,
we've negotiated with
movies, documentaries,
books, but it's very manual.
It's voluntary and it is not the,
uh,
it is not scalable. So
we're, we're making that, uh,
as a revenue stream for black legacy
newspapers that own their archives,
the photographers and the
archive groups. Okay, good.
Hi. Thank you ladies so much
for your information. Um,
it's going to be
beneficial to all. So, um,
my comment slash question is in the
form of money since you mentioned that.
And so my question is,
have either of you thought about any type
of fundraising efforts in order to not
only get your information out there,
but then also collect funds
at the same time? All right.
The tribe is actually celebrating
our second anniversary right now,
so we'll be having a huge
fundraiser on April 12th so yeah,
you'll be getting all of that information
and we don't have a fundraiser
scheduled, but we will.
It's, it's going to be as,
as new collections join the obsidian.
Our hope is to,
as we welcomed them to have a
fundraiser to celebrate because the,
the digitization takes time,
treasure, money, all of those things.
So we'll that, that's our strategy. Thank
you. I was going to ask you, you know, we,
you're here in Chicago,
so the Chicago defenders available,
but what about the other black newspapers
across the country? How urgent,
what's stat?
And can you give us an example of what
it's like going into the bowels of
whatever defined this material
and is some of it destroyed?
Is it salvageable at the other newspapers
saying Lincoln, Pennsylvania, or, uh,
you know, Amsterdam News in New
York? Yeah. So it's, it's, that's a,
that's a phenomenal question. When,
when we started with the defender,
the first thing I did was start talking
to other black legacy papers just to
kind of see where they were so we
can mirror what they were doing and,
and nobody was doing it. As,
you know, as journalism, uh,
institutions have shrunk.
The first thing you kind of put on the
side is the archive and you maintain the
journalism. So, um,
and then when things are so
different people have them,
different people feel they own them.
So we've got the lawyer's sorting all
of that out. But we've got a lot of,
we've got like eight legacy newspapers
in the queue that want to join the
Obsidian,
but most is local.
So in terms of rolling the
man and getting them digitize,
those are very specific to
the local community aspects.
And we're looking at partnering with
local Hbcu to partner with their library
science departments and get some of that
Labor go in and get this whole thing
kind of this big obsidian circle,
which is the logo of sitting in circle.
I can add on to that little
sure. Archiving. Um, again,
we do see the tribe, um, as a future, um,
source for these types of
materials because so many
newspapers and publications
have laid off photographers and people
who take videos and things like that and,
and a lot of millennials and youth,
we get our news from our phones. Um,
and from really kind of like
tabloid sites on, on Instagram and,
and Twitter,
like the shade room and things like that
where there's not real news and it's
people just aggregating materials.
So it's very important for us to be very
persistent and going out and taking new
images and capturing a
what Chicago is today.
That's one thing I love about you
guys is you're not just aggregating
entertainment and, and just actually make
a point, not, we don't aggregate at all.
Like we'd all go and say, oh,
this is trending right now.
We're going to just like copy and paste
with this peep with these people said,
because our whole thing is
since we have a small staff,
it's like if this story
is already being told,
there's no reason for us to like
tell it to. Yeah, yeah. You know,
we need to go in and tell the
stories that are not being told.
That's a great point with this big
black history month and I think it's
important, like you said, you need to
tell the stories that are not being towed.
Uh,
my name is crystal Allison and I tell
people I'm first generation great
migration to Chicago by way
of Arkansas and Tennessee.
And in that process I've been,
Angela and I have known each other
since high school and we've talked a lot
about amazing,
we talked a great deal about this and
I shared and I think that what is,
you know,
what she's doing is phenomenal.
And I just learned about the tribe today.
Angela Mia,
miss mentioned it and none of some
of our other conversations. But, uh,
when the movie the Butler came out and
I was at the advanced screening and it
was done by, um, what's his name? Um,
Lee Daniels. So talking about it because
they didn't know about that story.
So I was there for the Q and a, et cetera.
And I said, wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute.
The black man that was in the White House,
he was the highest level executive
in the White House at that time,
who happened to be one
of my relatives effort,
Frederick Morrow.
He Ha I knew the Eisenhower.
He was the first African American to
have the highest level position in the
White House when Obama ran for
president then a talked about it,
he here in there and buy Ebay because
I like to look stuff up as well.
I realized that he had written a book and
it was entitled Black Men in the White
House and he chronicled a lot of the
things that were going on in a lot of the
involvement that he had.
So as I spoke to the Daniel's,
I was gonna like and telling that story.
You also need to tell this story too
because he was a republican and he was a
lawyer.
And in addition his sister also
made some major inroads as well.
But it was kind of like I'm
learning like I didn't notice,
you know as well as I'm learning a
lot of other things. I didn't know.
One of my great uncles
was a Tuskegee airman.
He is going to be 99 years old this year.
So I think that what you
guys are doing on both sides,
on the millennials side and on this side,
that there are stories to be told.
There are photographs that are out
there that are in people's personal
collections. And so I'm not
sure if I missed part of it,
but what are you doing to get personal
collections included in your archives as
well?
Well or,
or how do you communicating that
this exists so that people who,
you know, cause some people
where as you're leaving us,
you know, the photographs,
you know,
like being buried,
thrown away or kind of locked in
somebodies a photo book and not being told
about,
well one of the things, uh, that uh,
personal archive collection actually kind
of falls under the category for us as,
as a small community archives.
So when the obsidian first
joined Google Arts and culture,
we put out a press release and we got a
ton of pickup because everybody was just
so excited about that.
And uh,
one of the phone calls I got was a woman
who had inherited her dad's collection
of 300,000 photos that
included 1960s Motown,
which is gold and 1960 Chicago,
which was awesome too.
And so many times people inherit these
wonderful collections of black legacy,
but they definitely want to retain
ownership. And most people think, well,
I've got to stand up a museum.
I've got to create my own foundation.
I've got to replicate this entire
thing and what we're offering.
And instead is a platform
for some of that.
But at the same time we're going to be,
uh,
having workshops and symposiums on how
to properly store and keep your own
archives and also what's valuable,
what's,
what's valuable to the world
and what's valuable to you,
which may be two different things, you
know, um, what, what happens when people,
things with, uh, a collection,
what happens when people leave
him with a museum or a university?
So we're going to do a lot of education
around protecting black history as well.
So our goal isn't to build
another blacksmiths, Sony.
And even though that place is amazing,
we're going to be doing,
we're focusing more on digital outreach,
even though we will have a location.
I mean, I think that there is, you know,
there's another museum that's
in the process of being built.
I forget where it's going to
be about that. Well, there's
always, I mean, we're not,
we're not, right. So there's all watering
that space, right? Exactly. Yeah.
So there's always room for I think,
four additional stuff because justice,
that museum has a lot of wonderful
stuff in there. As I was told,
they couldn't get everything
in there. So there's, you know,
again, more stories that are
out there to be told as well.
So it's good to see that they're both
platforms or forums here to provide that
as a mechanism for learning more because
I think it is important that we're
taught who we are and, uh,
learn more about ourselves.
Thank you.
Thank y'all very much. Okay. Come in.
And I wanted to ask you guys like,
I do y'all really inspire me here today.
Like listen to this a lot and it was
really interesting. I'm wondering, um,
it's fine. Are Ever gonna be part of
that? Like, you know, like, cause this, I,
you know, I'm 50, so I'm like
in between, uh, you know,
the millennial or whatever,
but I have seen,
I have my first piece in the museum when
I was 10, so I've seen fine arts. Yeah.
Like what about like Richard Hunt and
Kerry James Marshall and all those people.
Like they did some really cool,
interesting shit back in the day
on the tribe. We recognize that, um,
news isn't the only way to capture our
story. So we have a section on the site.
If you go to the top,
there's a tab that says the works and
it's just a space for creative works of
many different mediums from like
short films to photography are.
Um, so yeah, so we opened that up
for people to submit that type,
that type of material to,
yes.
Okay. Ben, let's get to know.
I'll check you guys out.
Yeah.
And,
and so we haven't been able to get into
the fine art space yet because that's a
different set of legal questions.
And,
and so right now we've got images and
who owns the image but put projecting
artists and something we've gotten to yet.
Yeah.
It was some really
beautiful things out there.
I agree with you on all over
Chicago old stuff. Yeah. Yeah.
I thank you a Morgan and Angela.
One more round.